jacques anouma temps brigitte bosser
pierre bénichou
voilà brigitte peut saisir des missions
vous arrivez donc du théâtre de la
renaissance vous avez joué grosse
chaleur
la nouvelle pièce de notre ami laurent
ruquier mise en scène par patrice
leconte
ça s'est passé comment très bien le
public est content parce que ça marche
bien parce que j'ai vu un reportage
jeudi soir sur france 2 où on voyait les
gens applaudir formidable alors
aujourd'hui on appréhendait un peu parce
que on a toujours un petit coup de mou
le jour de la deuxième
ouais et le public était vraiment au
rendez-vous et c'était formidable
presque aussi bien que le 1er juin moi
c'était un public payant 900 900 euros
la place
radi a pas de raison qu'on fasse payer
moins cher que du ram durable quel effet
ça fait brigitte d'avoir deux débutants
avec vous c'est à dire patrice leconte
qui n'a jamais fait de mise en scène de
théâtre et bénichou écouter en fait ce
qui est extraordinaire dans cette
histoire c'est que tous les
professionnels catherine arditi avec qui
j'ai déjà travaillé quatre fois amicales
anne benoît petit jean qui est acteur
professionnel bac ce soit qu'il ait très
peu travaillé
jean benguigui si vous voulez c'est nous
qui avons le trac pour lui parce que lui
il a il a le cadeau de la première fois
il
il a une espèce authenticité
extraordinaires ont fini par nous nous
remettre en question tous professionnels
audio non on n'a pas cet aplomb n'a pas
ce côté là les décomplexe exactement il
ya des matches où je vais résister dans
les commentaires qui végal que celle
qu'elle a lus n'allez pas voir les
répétitions j'ai deux conseillers au
public d'y aller dans les dix premières
parce quand il va se rendre compte si
l'acteur il va commencer à se regarder
jouer ça va être une catastrophe
maintenant alors pierre bénichou vous
êtes une venait de l'observateur depuis
de nombreuses années même directeur
délégué vous êtes une vedette dans les
dîners en ville vous êtes de meilleurs
invités de paris j'en ai été témoin et
maintenant vous êtes une vedette sur
scène alors est ce qu'on peut parler de
passeur un peu en fait en fait j'étais
assez naturel de l'avoir choisi laurent
parce que si une vedette dans la vie
s'ils veulent être sur les planches pas
envie de voir sur les planches évident
il fait tellement rire un radio
tellement rire à la télévision que
j'avais envie qu'il fasse rire parce que
quand il fait journaliste qui me fait
marrer
vous savez le thème je sais le texte oui
papa pas tout ouais
seulement ce que je dis moi ce que j'ai
cru qu'il fallait tout apprendre
ah oui c'est pour ça que je me suis
noyée au début maintenant je sais qu'il
faut seulement dire ce qu'avait il faut
savoir aussi quand c'est à vous de
parler donc une bien apprendre le texte
et autres vraiment là bas écoutez vous
avez remarqué qu'on est toujours écoutée
maintenant c'est le clr chiraquienne
écouter
égouttez le bonheur pour moi c'est un
truc formidable comme vous dites j'ai
beaucoup fait le clown avec mes copains
me suis dit un jour je fais quand même
monter sur les planches je vais voir ce
que c'est eh ben c'est pas terrible
cette époque raconte de faire moins
comme un team qui aime bien
qu'aujourd'hui un qui a 85 ans usé d'une
formule 1 oui les dégâts qui peuvent
faire alors à faire un concours de promo
brigitte pourquoi est ce qu'il faut
aller voir cette pièce qu'elle est drôle
et parce que les gens se marrent mais cc
c'est vraiment merveilleux et alors moi
j'ai vécu des jeux par des chasseurs
c'est aussi j'ai des angoisses pendant
tout pendant toute la pétition parce
qu'on n'y a pas de public
je me disais mais est ce que c'est
vraiment drôle et puis quand tout à coup
le public arrive alors là c'est le
cadeau mais maïga c'est vous et là tu es
formidable moi ça a été une découverte
aussi qu avait pas de public pendant les
répétitions se voir comme un cru à vous
maintenant au coeur
à vous maintenant pour une raison est ce
qu'il faut aller voir cette pièce il
faut y aller faut y aller parce que ses
parents quoi c'est marrant plus une
pièce qui est à double entrée c'est à
dire que c'est en même temps il pochade
et en même temps ils satire sociale
j'adorais 7,7 cette histoire parce que
c'est un mec qui a des principes
un psychorigide et j'ai toujours pensé
que les gens qui avaient les principes
pour des petites choses se conduisait
comme développe dès qu'ils étaient
confrontés une grande chose
un an lhasa mais qui fait chier toute sa
famille ont fait pas si on fait pas ça
on serait matin leur enfer comme ça et
le jour où on lui annonce que sa mère
vient de mourir
et là ils y perdent une foutue et j'aime
bien jouer les sommes perdues a terminé
très entouré merci beaucoup à celle
d'arnie la jambe gauche heures de
laurent ruquier mise en scène de patrice
leconte 7 au théâtre de la renaissance